it's Friday and to celebrate I'm going
to sit here and do this while Jess does
the rest of the introduction for this
top five news stories video I mean
there's really not much interleafed I
mean you're Dan I'm Jess and um hello
[Music]
we're gonna start a little bit
differently this week usually I'm the
one who talks about shooters but this
week I'm gonna throw it over to Jess
Jess what's happening in pub ji yes and
I did not research this one yes the
September update it's out now so what
they've done with updates is they used
to bring out a whole bunch of updates
with like little tweaks and bits and
pieces and then they have to roll some
stuff back and kind of take player
feedback what they're doing now is
having less updates but they're bigger
and this one really is bigger they've
added a brand new town on my way yeah so
just in the existing map yes in the
existing map so it's called kamesh key
and it's east of star bar if you're
looking for it or want to live there
they're also adding foggy weather so
it's gonna be harder to shoot people
obviously if you're in fog it's is
really spooky on top of that there's a
new item it's a mini 14 semi-automatic
marksman rifle okay don't know much
about guns but I think that's cool
that's a lot of work
Brydon sure more adjectives the better
there's also loads of UI and gameplay
tweaks as well as flight optimization on
low-end pcs in particular so that's
awesome that's great that's something
that I think pubget is crying out for
it's just a little bit more optimization
because even on our our powerful PC here
at work it was sometimes chug along yeah
not so hot yeah so a couple more things
um Idol player so I'm gonna get battle
points anymore
um which makes sense and they're still
working on faulting so I think you're
not bolting before they are looking to
add vaulting it's not coming in this
update they've said the algorithm is
quite complicated because there are so
many objects in the game but they're
working on it and it's an internal
process at the moment but you can expect
it something that's coming to Nintendo
held the direct this week and even
though they didn't have so many things
it was such a jam-packed direct all
anybody wanted to talk about was my
nipples algorithm is my iPhone
background is he's fantastic
Mario's shirtless in Super Mario to see
you can dress him up how
you want I'm personally waiting for a
tingle outfit because if I can't dress
Mario up as the fairy child man from The
Legend of Zelda then you know why I
haven't make the game I mean as one of
our friends said I think the most
upsetting thing about this whole saga is
now people are using the word niffle all
the time which is just Mario in relation
to nipples but that's that's because
there's a photo mode in Super Mario I
ought to see the chicken you can take
snaps happy snaps of Mario when he's
doing all kinds of stuff throwing his
cap Donal doing cool jump they also
shared some new worlds that look really
really cool and also showed off some of
the existing stuff there's so much more
way more we can't spend all that time
talking about Super Mario as much as I'd
love to what no I mean that wasn't
really like older like massively
breaking news the massive the breaking
news was that doom and Wolfenstein are
coming to switch that's huge it is huge
because Nintendo consoles are especially
the switch isn't currently really
supporting like my intense shooters yeah
but also not big third-party releases
that are coming out on the other
platforms you know around the same time
I mean that's to say what's scary when
Skyrim James obviously Blair's guy who's
been now for what six years but these
are like these don't come out last year
and Wolfenstein is coming out right on
October 27th of this year yes it's not
coming to situation for the next year
we'll come Stine no it's not and doom
will arrive on switch this holiday
season yeah and it looks like doom from
the 17 seconds we saw they didn't show
very much but but then stir seems to be
supporting the switch wholeheartedly
which is great which hopefully brings in
more third-party developers to really
want to support that handheld
yeah it's a team a COO hey Dan hey mate
you'll here to talk to us about
lawbreakers you sat down this week and
had a chat to Cliff Bleszinski
yeah so while breakers came out in
August you know it's the the next game
from the creator of Gears of War so you
know a lot of hype a lot of buzz around
it it had some you know pretty good
reviews a lot of positive critical
reception but the player based kind of
you know fell apart after you know not
very long for example I tried to get a
game on ps4 the other day here in
Australia and I was in matchmaking for
about 45 minutes didn't get a single
game which is unfortunate and obviously
we're in a bit of a different situation
here and I'll show you but the big
takeaway from my interview with cliff
was just the fact that he's aware that
you know the player numbers are very
very
oh and he was very humble and candid you
know speaking about that which is not
something that he always comes across
you know when you you might see his
interactions online and I was the other
thing too is he was representing how he
needs to be more well his quote was I
need to be less of a dick
so you could read into that however you
want but you know a boskie the developer
of law breakers is conducting a lot of
they're putting out a lot of new updates
and expansions you know to try to keep
people coming to the game there's you
know new maps coming new balance changes
new ranked mode there's also a new
onboarding experience which is what he
really wanted to make a point to say
that this is the thing that will help
people you know get into the game or
laps players you know bring them back
because I think a lot of the based on my
time with the game I wasn't exactly sure
what I was doing in my specific role so
I think this new onboarding experience
is going to try to help that out you
know it remains to be seen I mean some
games can be slow burners he pointed out
that you know a warframe the game from
Digital Extremes launched with you know
low player figures but then it's scaled
up over time as the developer stayed
committed to it so he's obviously hoping
that will happen with lawbreakers
remains to be seen if it will but if you
want to read our full interview it's on
GameSpot right now we'll have more
coming up next week this isn't something
we normally cover because it happened a
couple of weeks ago there was a huge
cough awful about half-life 3 half-life
2 episode 3 and the script came out maka
Laidlaw just published like a synopsis
of what it was going to be and everyone
was like is this real what's happening
it was real basically what happened is
Laidlaw was working on the script way
back when and then the NDA expired so he
was like well they never decided to use
it he did change the names not and he
called it epistle 3 mm-hmm and from that
someone made a game jam
yeah it's really cool so someone's
actually made a mod from the script it's
probably the first mod we're gonna say
obviously half-life mods are huge so
it's only a matter of time before
someone decided to turn that script
synopsis into a mod but it's only in
alpha stages now it's probably something
that they'll keep working on and if
I'm sure someone else will pick it up
but you're looking at it right now and
it looks kind of cool I mean you have to
remember this was created in a game jam
so it's limited limited time massively
limited but I think it's an awesome
thing that people are deciding to do I
mean there was a lot of disappointment
when this whole thing came out because
it was like oh wow they let the NDA
lapse it's been that long we're probably
never gonna see this game and I think a
lot of people felt super crushed who
were really attached to half-life and
you know the this massive game and dream
that that games gonna come out and now
it feels like it probably won't what do
you think Dan do you think we're ever
gonna say it half-life 3 no no if we do
it's gonna come completely out of left
field
I still say I'm under my favorite way
for valve to announce the half-life 3 is
out is for it to just suddenly be on
Steam would be amazing but I honestly
the longer it is the less likely it
seems like it's gonna happen but I think
this is a cool interesting thing that
we're gonna see and it's also this
modest thing developed by blender games
which are the guys who make
quadrilateral cowboy last yeah I mean
I'm interested to check this one out let
us know if you're interested as well and
if you ever think half-life fries gonna
come out I mean oh I hope so but I just
don't think it's likely this week was a
good week to be an old-school Nintendo
fan and a bad week to be a scalper who's
got what like 30s NES classic editions
just clogging up their house ready to
sell on eBay because they're extending
the supply the availability is now gonna
run through 2018 so suck on that
scalpers all those pre-orders that
you've got that you're trying to scalp I
now worthless because everyone's gonna
be able to get one it seems Nintendo
said that they after the NES classic
came out and was very hard to fill
demand they were gonna increase supply
for the SNES and it was still
outstripping the pre honest was still
out stripping their supply so they were
like you know what we're gonna extend it
into 2018 so that everyone who wants to
get one can get their hands on them yeah
that's not all they did and yes their
really cool thing is that the NES
classic edition is coming back as well
so if you missed out on that one I know
they sold out insanely quickly there
will be more units so you'll be able to
pick one up Nintendo was super adamant
that you should not be paying more than
the I think $90 that they're going for
and
it seems like they really delivered on
that I mean there was always gonna be
limited supply but it seems like they
can tell that there's demand and they
want to get those consoles in your hands
if you want to pick them up absolutely
similar story to the switch so that's
that's really nice it's a happy ending
it's a it's a good one yeah thanks
Internet
okay that is everything we got for you
guys this week thanks so much for
sticking with us as always do leave us
your comments down in that comment box
and make sure you have a good weekend
yeah definitely we'll see you guys on
Monday hey this week was a good week to
be a fan I am me
what kind of wake was this way Jess well
this week was a good week oh boy this
week was a good week to be an old